We're having a conversation,
I'm deciding I'm going to listen to you.
Right?
That's different than how people
generally communicate because usually
when they communicate,
they're doing something like,
okay,
we're going to have a conversation and
I'm going to tell you why I'm right and
all win.
If you agree or maybe you're having a
conversation where I don't know what
you're trying to do,
maybe you're trying to impress the
person you're talking to so you're not
listening to them at all.
You're just thinking about what you're
gonna.
Say Next.
Okay,
so that's not this.
This is.
You might have something to tell me and
so I'm going to listen on the off chance
that you'll tell me something that would
really be useful for me to know and so
you could take about it as an as an
extension of the Piagetian.
Piaget talked about the fundamental,
the fundamentally important element of
knowledge being to describe how
knowledge is sought,
the process by which knowledge is
generated.
Well,
if you agree with me and I find that
out,
I know nothing more than I knew before.
I just know what I knew before hand.
Maybe unhappy about that because it
didn't get challenged,
but I'm no smarter than I was before,
but maybe you're different than me and
so while I'm listening to you,
you'll tell me something I wouldn't.
I don't like.
Maybe it's something I find contemptible
or difficult,
whatever.
Maybe you'll find you'll tell me
something I don't know and then I won't
be quite as stupid and then maybe I
won't run painfully into quite as many
things.
And that's a really useful thing to
know.
Especially if you live with someone and
you're trying to make longterm piece
with them as they are not the same as
you and they're away.
They look at the world and the facts
that they pull out of the world aren't
the same as your facts and even though
you're going to be overwhelmed with the
proclivity to demonstrate that you're
right,
it is the case.
The two brains are better than one,
and so maybe nine of the 10 things they
tell you are dispensable or maybe even
49 out of 50,
but one thing all you need to get out of
the damn conversation is one thing you
don't know.
And one of the things that's very cool
about a good psychotherapeutic session
is that the whole conversation is like
that all you're doing is trying to
express the truth of the situation as
clearly as possible.
That's it.
And so now rogers' proposition,
and I'll tell you why he derived it,
was that if you have a conversation like
that with someone,
it will make both of you better.
It will make both of you with
psychologically healthier.
So there's an implicit presupposition
that the exchange of truth is curative.
Well,
that's a very cool idea.
I mean,
it's a very deep idea.
Uh,
I think it's the most profound idea.
It's the,
it's the idea upon western civil upon
which Western civilization,
although not only Western civilization,
is actually predicated the idea that
truth produces health.
But for Rogers that was entire purpose
of the psycho therapeutic alliance.
You come to see me because you want to
be better.
You don't even know what that means
necessarily.
Neither do I.
we're going to figure that out together,
but you come and you say,
look,
things are not acceptable to me and
maybe there's something I could do about
that.
So that's the minimal precondition to
engage in therapy.
Something's wrong.
You're willing to talk about it
truthfully and you want it to be better.
Without that,
the therapeutic relationship does not
get off the ground.
And so then you might ask,
well,
what relationships are therapeutic and
answered.
That would be if you have a real
relationship,
it's therapeutic.
If it isn't,
what you have is not a relationship.
God only knows what you have.
You're a slave,
they're a tyrant.
You know you're both butting heads with
one another.
It's a primate dominance hierarchy
dispute.
Oh,
I didn't know.
You're like two cats in a barrel or two
people with their hands around each
other's throats.
But what you have is not a relationship.
So alright,
we may say that the greater the
communicated congruence of experience,
awareness and behavior on the part of
one individual,
that's a reference to the same idea that
I was describing with regards to yoke.
So let's say you come and talk to me and
you want things to go,
well,
well I'm going to have to more or less
be one thing because if I'm all over the
place,
you can't trust any continuity in what I
say.
There's no end.
There's no reason for you to believe
that I'm capable of actually telling you
I'm capable of expressing anything
that's true.
So the truth is something that emerges
as a consequences of getting yourself
lined up and beating all the.
What would you call all the impurities
out of your,
out of your soul,
for lack of a better word.
You have to be integrated for that to
happen and you do that at least in part
by wanting to tell the truth.
The more the ensuing relationship will
involve a tendency towards reciprocal
communication with the same qualities.
So one of the things that I've been
quite influenced by Rogers,
one of the things I tried to do in my
therapeutic sessions is first of all to
listen to really listen and then we'll,
well I listen,
I watch and well I'm listening.
Things will happen in my head,
you know,
maybe I'll get a little image of
something or I'll get a thought or a
question will emerge and then I'll just
tell the person what that is.
But it's sort of directionless,
you know?
It's not like I have a goal except that
we're trying to make things better.
I'm on the side of the person.
I'm on the side of the part of the
person that wants things to be better,
not worse.
And so then those parts of us have a
dialogue and the consequence of that
dialogue is that certain things take
place and then I'll just tell the person
what happened.
And it isn't that I'm right.
That's not the point.
The point is,
is that they get to have an hour where
someone actually tells them what they
think.
Here's the impact you're having on me.
You know,
this is making me angry,
this is making me happy.
This is really interesting.
This reminds me of something that you
said an hour ago that I don't quite
understand,
and the whole,
the whole point is not for either person
to make the proposition or convinced the
other that their position is correct,
but merely to have an exchange of
experience about how things are set up
and it's extraordinarily useful for
people because it's often difficult for
anyone to find anyone to talk to that
will actually listen.
And so another thing that's really
strange about this listening is that if
you listen to people,
they will tell you the weirdest bloody
things so fast.
You just cannot believe it.
So if you're having a conversation with
someone and it's dull,
it's because you're stupid.
That's why you're not listening to them
properly because they're weird.
They're like wombats or albatrosses or
rhinoceroses or something like they're
strange creatures.
And so if you are actually communicating
with them and they were telling you how
weird they really are,
it would be.
It would be anything but boring.
So.
And you can ask questions.
That's a really good way of listening,
but you know one of Roger's points as
well.
You have to be oriented properly in
order to listen and the orientation has
to be.
Look what I want out of this
conversation is that the place we both
end up is better than the place we left.
That's it.
That's what I'm after,
and if you're not after that,
you got to think,
why the hell wouldn't you be after that?
What could you possibly be after that
would be better than that?
You walk away smarter and more well
equipped for the world than you were
before you had the conversation,
and so does the other person.
Well,
maybe if you're bitter and resentful and
angry and anxious and you know,
generally annoyed at the world,
then that isn't what you want.
You want the other person to walk away
worse and Youtube because you're full of
revenge,
but you know you'll get what you want if
you do that.
So we know from our research that such
empathic understanding,
so already defined that.
I want to hear you.
I want to hear what you have to say so
we can clarify it and move forward.
I want to have your best interests in
mind and mine as well,
but you know both at the same time your
families too.
If we could manage that,
we're after making things better.
We know from our research that such
empathic understanding,
understanding with a person,
not about him.
It's such an effective approach that it
can bring about major changes in
personality.
Some of you may be feeling that you
listen well to people and that you have
never seen such results.
The chances are very great that you have
not been listening in the manner that
I've described.
Fortunately,
I can suggest a little experiment that
you can do to test the quality of your
understanding.
The next time you get into an argument
with your wife or your friend or a small
group of friends,
stop the discussion for a moment and for
an experiment institute this rule.
Each person can speak up for himself
only after he has first restated the
ideas and feelings of the previous
speaker accurately would accurately
means is they have to agree with your
restatement.
Now,
that's an annoying thing to do because
if someone is talking to you and you
disagree with them,
the first thing you want to do is take
their argument,
make the stupidest possible thing out of
it that you can.
That's the straw man,
and then demolish it.
It's like so then you can walk away
feeling good about it and you primate
diamonds dominated them really nicely.
So,
but that isn't what you do.
You say,
okay,
well I'm going to take what you told me
and maybe I'm even going to make your
argument stronger than the one you made.
That's useful if you're dealing with
someone that you have to live with
because maybe they can't bloody well
express themselves very well,
but they have something to say.
So you make their argument strong.
Alright,
then you see what this would mean.
It would mean that before presenting
your own point of view,
it'd be necessary for you to really
achieve the other speakers frame of
reference to understand his thoughts and
feelings so well that you could
summarize them for him.
Sounds simple,
doesn't it?
But if you'll try it,
you'll find that it's the most difficult
thing that you've ever done.
Okay,
good.
We'll leave it at that and then we'll
see you on Tuesday.